who like
podcast uh yo reason is here man
one of the greatest i appreciate that
yeah
man last time you came to the radio
station and you did that freestyle for
us i was out of town
i know i think i was in i was in hawaii
yeah you know you were university
chilling yeah
yeah yeah so yo but yo man it's good to
have you here bro um
i've been sitting with your albums since
you sent it to me last night i
appreciate it
incredible body of work thank you thank
you there was like two songs on there
that were back to back it was fall
and the song after fall slow down
slow down yeah that was like you know
that's like my
back to back like i was like [ __ ] like
just very very like introspective like
just great storytelling like
we'll get into those records but i wanna
i wanna just kind of you know
you've been dropping songs i feel like
for the last year so yeah and they
they're all on this project but um not
not everyone not everyone yeah exactly
but um but like three or four of them
yeah like three or four of them um
talk about where you at right now and
why is you know why are we finally
getting you know
td we'd be having to wait for
[ __ ] on tv you know what i'm
saying
yeah it's funny because it's like that's
the mode it's kind of like not
necessarily to make people wait but just
to perfect
hold on dj head's calling me in the
middle of the [ __ ] hey yo i'm doing
an interview with you with carson's
finances why are you
[Laughter]
why are you always interrupting my [ __ ]
i need you to be on some put a shirt on
[ __ ] that's what i need you to be do you
have a shirt on
let me hit you back after this buddy
[Laughter]
anyway i got to answer dj heads like my
wife i got it like
something could be on fire right now
that's my dog that's my dog but yeah um
that's kind of been like the mode is to
just
make sure that we perfect you know what
i mean quality over quantity but
um i also feel like you know the world
being in the state that it was in was
kind of weird too
you know we were supposed to drop um
last year but just uh you know trying to
make sure that everything was right
and then when we were going to drop this
earlier this year in march
um you know covey hit of course and then
we were gonna drop again when we finally
understood like okay like let's just do
it you know we're gonna go in june
and then a lot of the black black lives
matter stuff yeah and people were
passing and we just felt like it would
be disrespectful to you
pushing music at that time um so it was
just like a lot of adjusting you know
what i mean in real life and i feel like
people forget sometimes that
because we're tde that like we gotta
adjust to like we don't just work on our
own
you know i mean merit or whatever the
case may be so and we respect the things
that's going on but uh
i think we're in a good place now like
the whole label you know what i mean and
i'm proud to be the one to start kicking
it off
give me some of your um background man
like obviously you're from carson yeah
um i had heard of you before
you were working with tde um you were
you know
i would say like you know like if you
were tapped in with two dope boys and
some of the blogs like
you were familiar with what you were
doing and then td became a part of the
situation and that just kind of made
[ __ ]
like super big but how long have you
been making music man like when did you
first start taking this rap [ __ ] series
um i actually blessed blessed enough i
actually only been making music for six
years so i started in 2014.
wow yeah yeah and um i've been heavy in
the music just because i
i liked it like i just liked lyricists
and and rappers that you know i mean
really rapped about stuff and whatnot so
i was super heavy into that
and then um i played ball and i was
supposed to go to greece to play
basketball
out there and then um one day i just i
just kind of fell out of love with it on
a
business level because i was like you
know i love basketball but i don't
really want to do a business thing with
it
and so i just called my agent and i was
just like no i'm probably not going to
go
and then um what year was that and that
was like beginning of 2014. so that was
like the beginning of 2014 i was still
in college
um so i called him um told him that and
then there was a part of me that
like and that's kind of what new
beginnings symbolizes and we'll get into
that but it was a part of me that was
kind of scared to do that because
basketball was my comfort i knew that i
can go make money playing basketball
like i knew that
like i committed there's anything else i
can do i can pay my rent there's
anything else i can do i can go play
basketball and make some money
and i was like do i really want to give
up this comfort you know what i'm saying
in this comfort zone or whatever
to do something else and potentially
fail you know what i mean and so
um i ended up making a decision um and
even after i told him i still was kind
of like
50 50. i'd call him some days i'd be
like well wait hold on
but then when i graduated and um i wrote
a song called letter to god which is
like my second song that i wrote
and um i sent it to my brother and we
listened to it and after that that was
that song kind of got me over to fear i
was like i'm i
i i think i'm really good at this [ __ ]
let me just try it
a shot yeah exactly so so where did you
go to where did you play
uh basketball is that a d2 called
northwestern state in iowa there's like
a
a swarm of northwesterns in the midwest
um it's like northwestern oklahoma
northwestern iowa i feel like there's a
million northwest there's a bunch in
northwest
yeah it's like this little like weird
yeah middle of nowhere it's it was awful
so were you a point guard because you're
yeah i'm not tall enough to yeah
be anything else 100 yeah i mean it's
it's it's crazy because i i
like the basketball hustle like you said
like going to greece
like i got i got some homies who who
live in europe and who hoop and like you
said like it's like
you know if you love basketball and
you're like d
like you're good like there's always
like always a place to make pay your
rent there's always a way to make money
if you could pay a rent playing
basketball bro it's like now and that
was my thing i'm like
like i'm seeing all my my homies like
you know work jobs and stuff and
they hate their job and i'm like like
even though i might not like where i'm
at over there at least i like my job
like what i'm saying and i can pay my
rent doing it or whatever the case may
be but
i just had two nieces and i was in iowa
for two years and i wanted to come back
home i went through like a little racial
situation out there with my coach
and um it was just like i was just like
you know i don't know if i'm ready to
leave again you know what i mean and so
that was kind of like part of the uh the
the influence behind it was
i don't know if i'm ready to leave and
then on top of that um
i was using music as as like therapy
like i was writing out there just to
kind of pass the time because i was out
there it was only me and like six other
black people at the school so i didn't
really have nobody yet i didn't really
have nobody to talk to relate to
so i was just kind of writing as kind of
like a therapeutical thing and i started
liking it
so i was like man let me just you know
record a couple things so i came home on
spring break and recorded
a couple records and that's kind of when
i decided like you know i'm just going
to do this and see how it works out
when you say you had a racial situation
with your coach what happened um
basically um i had a coach that uh i
mean he was racist
to to you know keep it fun yeah to keep
it funky we used to it was me and three
other black players
we used to have black only meetings
before the games um that you guys
conducted or that
he would be like i just want to meet
with the three black guys and talk to
them about
how they need to play to fit into like
this
role like and then he would like say the
n word to us like in metaphorically like
so not at us but he's still
saying yeah right right um one time he
used this example where he was like you
know he was like white people are the
brain
black people are the soul mexicans are
the heart
because you know they work hard and uh
you know make everything go he was like
when you put all three of them together
it's a beautiful thing but if you had to
pick one
wouldn't you rather be the brain like
that like well to be honest if he wanted
to use that reference
i would argue that asian asian people
are the brain
but everything yeah and i would also
argue that you know the heart's kind of
just as important as
you know being honest my people might be
like the kneecaps or something i don't
know
i feel like we're not bringing a lot to
the table at 2020. not in 2020 right now
shit's [ __ ] up man a thousand percent
so yeah like i went through that
situation and it's funny even with that
situation
like the naacp was getting involved and
stuff and it was about to be big and
i was younger right and so if i had my
brain that i had now i would have
carried it all the way through and went
because i i feel like
i could have changed some things over
it's an intimidating fight for kids yeah
yeah like when i was in i was like i
just want to go home bro like if y'all
can make it to where i can go home after
the season and just
like work do my schoolwork from home and
come back to graduate and leave again
then like we got a deal and my mom
didn't want me to do that she wanted me
to stay and fight
um but i just ended up saying like you
know like i just want to come home so
that's what they let me do after the
season was over i went home i worked
from home
did all my schoolwork from home sent it
in they kind of just passed me because
they were just they're like we don't
want
to just get over here we don't want no
smoke like so i was kind of just turning
in without this guy still coaching
he is unfortunately there he is
unfortunately yeah what the [ __ ]
yeah and if you've been to that town
it's like it's one of those places that
it's like bro nothing to never change
there because there's nothing there like
there's nothing there to make it
you know what i'm saying like change and
that's the reason why that is one regret
that i do have i hate having regrets in
life but
if i could go back i would fight that
you know right because he doesn't need
to be coaching like to just to be
completely honest hey put his name out
there so people can
you know i honestly legally can't oh
you're not legally can't you well the
coach of
yeah north western iowa you [ __ ] sucker
it's not hard to find though like people
can look at google it yeah people can
look and find what college i went to for
sure for sure but yeah
yeah that's unfortunate yeah it's crazy
um
and just really quick uh the crazy thing
about it is that so he has a nephew
that's in the nba right now
that is complete opposite like he does
like
podcasts and stuff about racial
discrimination against black
white guy j.j reddick i told you i can't
i can't say what it is but
like it's crazy the opposites though
like he is like his nephew was like
hard working fighting against like
racial
racial discrimination we'll talk about
it i listen to the jj podcast
he has he actually does have a great
podcast i just got hit to it like
recently yeah that's dope man yeah i'm a
huge basketball guy so yeah
i actually don't listen to as much man
it sucks because
i listen to like certain [ __ ] like i'll
like gravitate to an album
yeah and then i'm just stuck with it
like i'm still listening to [ __ ]
like freddie gibbs and alchemist alfredo
which was incredible though for sure but
and then like
outside of that i'm just i'm just
listening to sports talk radio like a
degenerate
sports gambler but um yeah man that's
that's wild i didn't know that about you
bro yeah you know i was it was a crazy
situation you know what i mean and it's
uh
um it's weird because like when i write
music i never know what i'm going to
touch on so i feel like one day it's
something that i'm going to touch on but
i never come into songs like
purposely right like so i'm just like
one day it'll come spilling out and i'll
talk about it you know what i mean
so yeah yeah no that's wild i think that
um i think that's important too for you
to share that because i'm sure there's
people
who are going through maybe similar
situations maybe not on a basketball
team but
yeah like whether it's their boss or
corporate environments anything
yeah man it's just [ __ ] up right now
like and
people get people got to stand up for
what's right bro yeah yeah
i mean but i will say in 2020 um
because of how chaotic it is like there
always has to be balance and i feel like
like there's more than ever more white
people than ever that's
trying to understand and i always tell
black people in general like
you know don't criticize white people
that are trying to understand that maybe
don't understand it because that's step
one you know what i'm saying is them
trying to
understand it i think that what sucks
about right now is like kind of what you
just said like
if there's no nuance and there's no
room for progress and if it's like
hey yo [ __ ] you off the rip because
you're not exactly where i want you to
be as opposed to like
you're trying you're trying you know
like you know what i'm saying i think
that that's
there's two opposite ends of the
spectrum and i think that's the other
opposite end of the spectrum where it's
like
you know there's people who like you
said like they might not have known
about
i mean and what's crazy it's yeah it's
crazy but it's like you have to
understand that people's reality or
their reality like some people
genuinely are unaware like yeah this
stuff was going on but they didn't know
but they didn't know
they didn't know that it was like and i
tell people all the time like you got to
be
understanding bro to people people's
environments like you know what i mean
like there's people out there that
they have nothing against black people
and but they literally
might not have a black person in their
life there might be people who just
don't grow up like in
in that environment exactly like there's
people who grow up in [ __ ] salt lake
city and all they know is like white
mormon kids you know what i'm saying
because you know and if they're trying
to be empathetic i just think that
they're
we're losing like a lot of nuance in the
world where it's like
you're either this or you're this yeah
yeah but what if you're like here or
here like you know what i'm saying
you're trying to get
here you're getting upset yeah yeah i
think even politically it's just [ __ ]
up because i
i feel like you can't like i can
criticize joe biden
and still say i'm voting for joe biden
it's a fact you know what i'm saying
like i
i i don't [ __ ] with joe biden really
yeah but i'm not voting for donald trump
exactly like you know what i'm saying
but i can like there's like nuance like
you got to be able to
like you know ask questions and be
critical and
and just because you're critical doesn't
mean like you ain't
you ain't for whatever the [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying exactly well the issue
is that we're in an environment right
now where it's like
everybody jumps out the window for
everything like it's like you can't be
you can't even have a conversation about
something it's like you got to pick you
get them saying like you have to pick
what it is
right now and if you don't and you even
play the fence
then it's like you know then they're
just going to label you like okay well
then you're over here you're saying and
so yeah
like i was like a big bernie sanders
supporter and um
and i had people like dig up tweets i
said about joe biden like yo man you
[ __ ] you don't even [ __ ] with this
i'm like yeah like
obviously i'm not like crazy about joe
biden like
he's probably the least candidate at on
that side that i would welcome
but you know what the other side is is
terrible
[ __ ] hitler you know like the worst
possible [ __ ] in the world
like i would vote for like anybody like
literally anyone else like that
it could be george w bush like i'm
running the
g-dub vote you know what i'm saying like
[ __ ] it run iraq backwards joe biden
would have to personally
put out an attack on my family for me
joe biden would have to put out like an
entire like
this album like just dissing every race
ethnicity
sexually come on bro like
it's crazy nah that that's dope though
man so
um the fact you didn't start making
music until 2014
now were you writing before that or was
it something that like
um it was like i wasn't really writing
um i have some homeboys that rapped and
i would like
like kind of be with them in the studio
just on some kicking and [ __ ] i would
kind of like be like oh you know you
should say this you should say that
right right you used to always tell me
like
you kind of like you kind of tight with
like words and [ __ ] like that you know
what i mean but
it was never something that i was taking
in any type of way recording or nothing
like that just because when i when i
focus on something and this is a good
thing in a flaw i'm like tunnel vision
when i focus on [ __ ] so oh yeah
i can't do basketball and music i can't
do music
and something else see what i'm saying
like it's like i have to
focus on one thing and you know what i
mean like that's just kind of how i am
so
i wasn't able to really do it until
basketball was off the table
you know what i mean and so and it shows
that way but
i've been blessed because things have
just kind of worked very fast you know
in comparison to other people that
haven't i mean you're one of the jedi's
man
like literally you're you're one of
those guys that's like you know what
you're getting with reason you know
that's that's love that's right
and uh and and that's that's i mean six
years is not a long time man
especially in hip hop like just people
have been doing this [ __ ] for 20 years
before
we we you know we know who they are you
know what i'm saying that's wild
so um 2014 you start making music you
leave the basket basketball [ __ ] alone
yeah
um what was the in your opinion the
moment that
you realized there were some eyes on you
that like okay this is this actually
really might work yeah
yeah um i remember i was doing this
thing called reason fridays where i just
like freestyle every friday and i was
putting it out and it was leading it was
actually leading up to there you have it
so
right um i dropped like 10 of them like
10 weeks in a row leading up to the drop
of that project
and like around the eighth one um things
just kind of started picking up like
first i got posted by like a couple of
professional athletes like brandon
jennings shout out to him
how brandon jennings man yeah he looked
out uh todd gurley
um it was a couple of dudes and then um
then baller alert posted me and then
after that
like a few like low-level label reps
started reaching out and we had a couple
meetings so that's kind of when i
realized
that some eyes were on me um but then i
started talking to a dude named
tubby sean holliday shout out to tubby
he was like the first high level
uh executive um he was the vp at anr's
at um
uh i want to say sony at the time and uh
he brought me into his office and uh
played him a bunch of records i played
him better days and after better days he
was like
if you can get me like six more of these
like then like you know we can
we can go but things never kind of
progressed um
just because you know labels and this is
no offense to tubby at all like i love
tubby because he was actually one of the
first people to like start
talking to people about me um but labels
the big labels they don't really want to
develop artists they kind of want to
keep an eye on you until you kind of
start bubbling you know what i mean
they want you to do all the ground what
you do all the ground work they come in
and they pull you over the finish line
exactly
what i'm saying like and so you know
that was kind of where where tubby was
he was like you know like i just want
him to kind of get cracking first you
know what i mean
and what's crazy is that tubby sent my
music to top
and he wanted to do a joint deal with
top because he was like you know i'm not
going to get him cracking but i know top
can get him cracking
and he wants to do a joint deal with top
but top doesn't do joint deals so top
never even listened to my [ __ ] like he
was just like
as soon as tubby started talking about a
joint deal he was just like well you
know i'm not interested yeah and then
when i met top years later top digs in
his emails and it's the same songs that
i'm playing him in the studio he like
wow like this [ __ ] has really hit
unopened email like what's up yeah i
think that that is one
dope thing about tde um
you know is the the the development
process
you know like they there's a dope young
mc uh
who you guys have under your roster that
i've known for a long time
um he's wearing the chain i don't know
if it's official so i'm not going to say
his name
but like i i mean he's been on the label
about a year and like
just working yeah yeah you know working
on his craft
and they got he showed me some videos
that y'all have shot and yeah
you know it's like that kind of like
attention to detail and like
you know that [ __ ] is is is um
as a fan it could be frustrating yeah
yeah from the fans
because i'm like i need a [ __ ] isaiah
ever shot album bro by the way glad he's
on the album but
but no just in general i just think that
that's something that's that's that's
missing from the game and the process
now because like
you know like you said man these labels
low key are kind of hoeing everybody man
because
they want you to do everything yeah yeah
and then once it gets to a certain point
now obviously once the label comes
involved like
there are looks and radio players oh you
know there's things that
that that they can offer that people
still can't right
there are still some things but like if
you're like
you know i would just say most artists
just keep grinding right a little longer
build up your uh
you know your your uh
your leverage with these fools a
thousand percent like i tell people that
all the time like if you
if you don't have a seat like signing
with a major label to me in this day and
age
it's just not smart now if you're gonna
sign with like a uh
well when you don't have the leverage um
if you because you're going to get a
really bad deal you're going to get a
really bad deal regardless there's
nothing you don't matter how talented
you are you could be michael jackson
you're going to get a real really bad
deal
so to me it's smarter to sign with like
some of these lower
management companies and stuff like that
like shout out to lvrn they're doing an
incredible job they're killing it yeah
you know what i mean they're killing it
um
you know the tdes the dream bills
whoever it is you know a lot of people
look at td as a major and we're not you
know i mean we're independent ladies
yeah no that's what i'd be trying to
tell people is like yo if you're on tde
that doesn't mean you're like
me you're an interscope you so you're
just strictly td
you're just strictly cd yeah so
absolutely exactly and the same thing
with me like we're trying to build up
leverage that way when we do take it to
a major we get the deal that we want you
know what i mean we get the situation we
want
um which top is top he can get whatever
he wants but at the same time
it's more organic to be able to build
that up and show your value first you
know what i mean 100
when you first became involved with tde
um
like i feel like what's dope about a
brand like td a brand like dreamville
it's like they're flying their fans are
so open like open-armed yeah like
yeah you're one of us now oh yeah so you
automatically step into like
to like 20 000 die-hard
we hit it with fans like did you see
that right away like
a thousand percent like tdd fans are
like the they're the dopest most
crit overly critical in the world
they're smart hip-hop fans they're smart
hip-hop fans and uh sometimes almost too
smart like when i
because i talk to a lot of my fans um
sometimes to a fart like uh my managers
tell me like you know i got to be
more ducked off but um but i talk to
them because i am a fan
too and i want to know how they feel but
um sometimes i tell them i'm like yo
y'all listen to music sometimes and
don't enjoy it like because you're too
busy
like being critical or trying to decode
what it is like you're not even
like like about show like roll the blunt
like just sit back relax
yeah and listen it's music you know i
mean it's entertainment but nah shout
out to all the td fans and the
dreamville fans i want to tour with jid
and realize that a lot of them cross
over yeah you know what i mean like a
lot of them do it they definitely love
both of us
yeah um what was uh
what was the record that caught tops
attention do you remember like which
record or what what it was that like
yeah that got you that meeting with top
yeah well better days is the one that
really really caught
tops attention but the one that made top
feel like yo like this dude can like
make records because
that's top's big thing right now it's
like yeah you can rap but can key making
can you make records
exactly and it was on there you have it
it was called [ __ ] with me and when he
heard that record he was like
yo like yeah this dude he can go you
know what i mean and it wasn't even
we weren't even supposed to sign like
musa was taking me to him we were
actually supposed to be doing something
with uh with dave gross shout out to
dave gross he would do a lot of stuff
with nip
and we were supposed to be doing like a
little partnership deal with dave and
and dave shows a lot of love and he was
going to help me build up a little bit
and then the plan was to go to top and
moose kept listening to the music that i
had and
without me even saying so he just took
it to top and then top was like you know
like let's sit down and have a meeting
and uh i was playing music for like an
hour tops not bobbing his head and
nothing like that ain't not giving me
nothing like he's showing moose memes
and [ __ ] i'm like smells disrespectful
that's the worst when you're playing
someone music and they're they're on
their phone
you know out of my eye trying to like
see if he's [ __ ] with it like he's
just not
and then [ __ ] with me played and that
was the first time that he kind of like
put his phone down and started bobbing
his head
and so i leave the meeting i'm low-key
like depressed i'm like that [ __ ] did
not go well and moose tells me he's like
no you gotta understand my pops like
if he didn't like it you would you
wouldn't have been here for an hour like
he don't you don't do that you know what
i mean he was like so
you know he was like a deal might not
happen today or next month or whatever
but you know like let's just keep
working and go back to dave and regroup
and
we'll come back and then like three days
later moose called me and he was like i
think my pops gonna sign you and i was
just like what the [ __ ] like this is
crazy you know what i mean
so it happened way faster than i thought
um and
you know that was also part of the
reason why i feel like it took a little
longer for me to
drop some stuff after i signed because
me and top still had to get to know each
other
as people you know what i'm saying
because it's such a people label yeah
for sure yeah yeah so we have to
still build that you know what i mean
it's a family business exactly 100
people forget that like yeah
yeah it's a family business like top
will not sign you if you don't if you
don't
personally [ __ ] with you he'll just take
you and get you signed somewhere else
and get a piece of your contract like
yeah yeah exactly on everything no
that's crazy
yeah i think that uh you know it's been
dope to see your development because
you've been dope for so long and i think
that
you're i feel like this album is like
your coming out party if that makes
sense
yeah yeah that's how that's how i
approached it too there's so many things
happened
over the last couple years like you know
i think that that lambo truck record was
so
[ __ ] special on that dreamville album
thank you obviously you know
like you said you went on tour with jid
and like
you know you've been just kind of like
it's been like a tumbleweed just
accumulating more and more
like momentum and i think that you know
now's the time um talk about the album
man because there's a lot of personal
[ __ ] on the album
there's a lot of moments on the project
that were like
like oh [ __ ] moments like damn this [ __ ]
is like crazy like
thank you um how did you approach this
[ __ ] did you approach it kind of like
you know because you didn't tell all
your story obviously yeah yeah
and i didn't even completely dive all
the way into it it's funny some of the
more personal ones
um were records that were supposed to be
on my debut album that i'm working on
right now so i consider this like a
project so this is like a mixtape it's
like a mixtape kind of
whatever we're calling it is that
whatever it's funny because i hate when
artists do that but now i'm that guy and
now
that guy i'm definitely that guy but uh
yeah it's kind of like a mixtape or a
project or a collection of songs
and it's funny because when we made it
we were like damn we need some [ __ ]
for like the core fans like because it's
not personal enough you know what i mean
and that's kind of when we added
uh the slow downs and um um the gossips
and the falls
um and then uh windows cry didn't get
added until
top called and wanted to add it which is
crazy because of the content on there
um but top caught and was like nah that
should be the outro and so that's kind
of how we put it together but i
approached it from a celebratory
like stan like like point of view
because there you have it dropped
originally in 2016.
and so i got a bunch of day one fans
that's been riding with me and they see
me
they see me get signed and we redrop
there you have it and they're like yeah
that's great for you but like where is
it
where's the new music we've been heard
this [ __ ] and so i wanted to give
them something that i felt like they
would want to hear so i approached it
like i'm not even a
feature heavy type of artist but i was
like okay you know what do i want to
hear as a fan you know what i mean i
always want to hear zayn jin on the
record together like let me go do that
you know what i mean
uh rap city for the rap heads it's like
fire fire
yeah yeah she went crazy it's my
favorite feature on the [ __ ] so
when it did that i was like you know let
me take care of home let me bring soul
out the cave so we did trapped in we did
flick it up trapped in didn't make it
but flick it up of course made it
so i approached it from that standpoint
like from a fan standpoint and
let's make fun records let's make you
know what i mean let's get
dope features let's get [ __ ] like that
dope production and then we came back
and added
the personal elements and so that's kind
of how i attacked it from putting it
together as a whole project
yeah on the album um fall is a record
that i thought was really dope because
you know the first verse is you rapping
from the perspective of like an upcoming
female
artist who you know and i do think that
that's something that's
kind of unsaid in music like i even
think like
when we think of female mcs like
i think like and it's unfortunate like
rhapsody's on the album yeah and
rhapsody to me is the best
yeah to me and one of the best overall
overall mc's like i think she's like top
five
at at very very minimum top 10 mc's
period no no she's like yeah she's up
there but like as a female she's like
that she's like yeah she's but i feel
like
it sucks because she's not overly
sexualized people don't give her that
respect and that's
and that's not like i i give her that
respect but i feel like
because she's not an overly sexualized
female artist that's a fact
she doesn't get the respect that she
deserves and that's just kind of like
the the world we're [ __ ] in like you
know what i'm saying is
it's tough like but i thought that was
dope like
like was there anybody in mind like when
you wrote that like like
you don't want to see anybody's name but
was there something well actually um rap
that's how we met so when that verse on
on fall which i personally think is the
most important record on the album
because of that
um that verse about female mcs and about
and the second
verse yeah and the second verse too as
well you get them saying and um uh but
uh unfortunately because of what we just
talked about
i was a late rap city fan i didn't get
put on to layla's wisdom and i'm on tour
with rock and i'm listening
and i'm like yo what the [ __ ] like like
she is crazy yeah
and kendrick had been putting in work
for like 10 years and i didn't i was
just wasn't hip you know what i mean
so um i wrote the verse and i actually
even say on the verse i say
i had a convo with layla sharing some of
her wisdom with me came to kick it with
me so
i wrote it from her perspective and i
didn't write the second verse yet and
she was following me on twitter
and so i just reached out to her and was
like hey i wrote a verse about you like
i just want to send it to you so that
you can hear it like
it's special to me and um i sent it to
her and she called me and she said that
she started tearing up listening to her
because she
she had stories about that where people
were talking to her and telling her how
she needs to like sexualize herself a
little bit more and she was just trying
to stick to the core
and she said you know that whole she
just want to be artists like she felt
that
because that's all she was like i just
wanted to rap and make music you know
what i mean
and so that's how we made our our
connection and then after that a couple
months later was when i sent her i can
make it and then you know we ended up
doing that so she was definitely the one
that was on the so she was the
when i heard it i was like yo this [ __ ]
like just reminds me of like
like because i've been a rhapsody fan
for so long yeah um
and you know it just
i i was like how is she not more
respected and it's really like
it's just because we have such a shallow
industry that we're in and really just
like fans are so
also shallow fans are shallow yeah yeah
like yeah
you know what i'm saying like not every
fan like it you know it's unfortunate
and you know i used to be guilty of that
when i was like younger you know what
i'm saying like but
i definitely think like that's an
important verse and then even the second
verse
and this is something that i think is
finally i feel like starting to kind of
die out
yeah i feel like a lot of the young
artists that i'm meeting aren't drugged
out of their minds exactly
but for like two or three years bro like
2017 2018 last year like
it's it was rough because everybody we
would have come by the radio station
would be [ __ ] high as [ __ ] no 100
and not understanding the damage like
and that's why to me that that song like
i said is uh to me the most important
record on the on the project because
it's like not only is is this industry
affecting like the quote-unquote street
[ __ ] that come in and how they
are with drugs and stuff like that too
um but that's the reason why
even though he's so loved and i love him
too you know rest in peace mac miller
that's why i mentioned his name was yeah
i heard you mention his name i i wonder
if you're gonna catch some flack for
that yeah
and i might but at the at the end of the
day like i pride myself on being like
one of the
more honest artists out here and um i
love mac miller and
it's a it's a tragedy what happened but
the reason why i mentioned his name
was to show the industry like it's for
the people that's going to say well
it's just these artists that are
affected by it and it's not
just not just the little clouds this is
a great kid no matt miller was like one
of the greats
he was like one of the great parts and a
great continuity and a great guy and a
nice guy
in this industry in my opinion you know
what i mean destroyed him
it's not just the young boys it's not
just the young boys and that was the
reason why i did it i was like you know
there's a chance that i could catch some
flack but i feel like this is so
important
for people to understand is that like
it's not just the littles it's like
this industry affects everybody
especially the
the the the kids that are stars young
like mac miller has been in this [ __ ]
since he was like eight
yeah you know what i mean so it's like
when you grow up in this industry you
almost don't even have a shot
unless we start changing how we approach
kids like these are kids bro you know
what i mean we're putting certain things
in front of their face
and expecting them you know how are you
as a 15 year old going to be
in the studio with one of your idols and
he offered you a blunt and not hit the
blunt like you know what i'm saying like
it's so for sure it's like we got to
start taking more accountability
or like if you're yeah or and like you
said i mean weed is one thing but like
how are you going to be in the studio
with whoever and let's say they got zans
or they're
sniffing lines like bro and these are
your idols you're like
i don't want to look like the guy that's
like you know what i mean like it's the
running joke like oh snoop pass me a
blood i don't smoke but snoop has been
blunt
like you don't say like that's like i've
been i've done that
but i do smoke yeah but i also like yeah
i'm like
snoop passes you know like how are you
gonna do it exactly
the blood you don't agree with certain
people but it's like
yeah i think that you know i've been
i've been kind of you know shout out to
future he's one of my favorite artists
but i was kind of critical of him pretty
heavily when it came to like just
the narrative he was pushing and he's
living his truth through his music but i
just think that
there was just an air of and it's still
going on you know
um but i just feel like there's this
whole wave of kids that were just
influenced by
by like that that kind of [ __ ] like i
think
i think you know the fact like mask off
was such
a big song mm-hmm let us write and the
whole hook is about
percocet molly what's the number one
wreck i got the plaque right yeah this
[ __ ] is black
that's the plaque yeah it's playing
20 000 times a day on the radio on the
radio bro and they're not bleeping out
during the set molly burke said they're
not bleeping it out yeah
exactly and that's my whole thing it's
like like for me it's like you know i i
never
i never mind catching flack if it's
something that i stand on and it's in my
morals you know what i'm saying like and
that's not to say that i'm perfect
because
you know there's times that i rap about
you know what i mean smoking or drinking
or whatever in case i
may be because i do it but i also tell
the other side of the story as well and
that's all i say for people is like
you know everybody live your truth you
know what i mean but
understand that like when you when
you're giving money and fame and all
this stuff like you still hold a certain
level of responsibility
and if it's artists that i am genuinely
enjoying am a fan of
i'm always going to hold you accountable
regardless and that doesn't mean that i
don't like you you know what i mean it
just means that i'm holding you
accountable because
you're in a position that you know you
are a role model to somebody you know
what i mean and if your fans
if i catch blackboard and your fans you
know feel some type of way about it
i'm okay with it if it's something that
i morally stand on you know what i mean
so that's kind of where i'm at with it
um also on the project um you talk about
losing losing a child
yeah the issue of you know abortion i
think that's something that
i i never personally went through but i
know you know a lot a lot of people have
yeah yeah and i haven't really heard
anybody really dive into that issue on
record
since like there was a comment in lauren
hill record when i was a kid that was
like
crazy but um yeah why was that important
to address because i feel like that's
something that you know
man that's a deep issue to dive into bro
yeah yeah for me
um it's funny as a defense mechanism i
do this thing where when i go through
stuff that bothers me i just kind of
forget about it and so um
writing about it was actually like the
first time i even talked about it like i
didn't even tell my brother as close as
we are that that happened uh just
because i just kind of wanted to forget
about it
you know unfortunately it was in a
situation where there wasn't a lot of
love in that situation and
um you know i i you know was the person
that
you know didn't didn't necessarily
like like tell her to do it but at the
same time was definitely like a guy
trying to lead her like this is going to
mess up my life or whatever the case may
be
and um um i regretted it not because
i wanted a kid at the time but just
because of the fact that
you know this is something that is so
sacred to a woman and a woman should be
able to have that you know what i mean
which she still ultimately had that
choice
but i was being guiding and so that's
why i talk about it in the record to
hold myself accountable and say
like i need to grow up like that's
that's childish to have that mindset
that's childish to
to be that way and to think that way you
know what i mean and so how long ago was
that
um that was probably like [ __ ] like two
and a half years ago oh [ __ ] that yeah
pretty recent yeah yeah exactly and so
for me it was just like you know i
wanted to
hold myself accountable for that and and
speak about it and
just for anybody else that's in that
situation to know like you know men have
to be men and you you make the bed you
got to lie in it you know what i mean
and
it should be her choice and if she wants
to do that then cool if she doesn't want
to do it then cool
but it should always be their choice you
know what i'm saying so i wanted to hold
myself accountable or not
yeah no i think that that's some real
[ __ ] like i think that you know
if you're like uh like you guiding your
narrative like hey look
we don't [ __ ] with each other like that
what i'm saying like you know what i
mean and sometimes
like you're pretty much saying like look
i really gonna be around like that you
know what i mean like 100 and then that
kind of influences her decision
and you know as opposed to just being
like hey it's on you whatever you want
to do on here
yeah exactly like you know where we are
like she doesn't need you to remind you
mind you of where you guys are you're
going to i'm sorry so that's my whole
thing it's like you know
y'all can have a completely have an
adult conversation about
what the circumstances are and all of
that i think that that part should
always be had you know what i mean but
it shouldn't be a guiding
conversation you know what i mean it
should be just a conversation around
where we are you know
money situation love yeah for sure and
then you know ultimately
you make your decisions that you make
your decision um how did uh
the show stop record come together with
the kendrick uh
what we call them ad-libs yeah kind of
like ad-libs yeah yeah
yeah cause that was like shout-out rock
i kind of took his swag on that i saw a
wind going crazy i was like i need some
i need some ad-libs man right
right right right right right yeah by
the way yeah shout out to but no like
how did uh like did you just grab those
vocals
from like a session or did he come in
and do it
nah because yeah that sounded like the
the the the record from um
the the black panther soundtrack you
know travis was it off of that uh not
the ideas were birthed though from that
and when it was birthed from those
records and uh i had showstopper already
and we were already talking about it
being a single and i was trying to get a
verse i'm not gonna lie
exactly of course like i'm gonna swing
for defenses i was trying to get a verse
um but i started to slowly realize in
the conversation that ad-libs are more
reasonable you know what i'm saying and
uh it's funny because fans will be
giving me slack they're like oh
kendrick's
oh he just did the atlas i'm like [ __ ]
it took me six months to get these ad
libs like y'all better
enjoy these ad-libs like it took me a
long time to get
those ad-libs from dot you know what i
mean like to a point to where i thought
they weren't coming
um and it's funny because even when he
did the ad-libs he did a whole track of
him
and i still like were like taking some
and plugging them in different places
and stuff like that
because he hit me and he was like you
know like i did the ad-libs but it feels
a little crowded
and then when i sent him the record back
you know we plugged him in certain
places he was like
okay cool that feels more natural or
whatever because he even when he sent
him to me he didn't really like how it
sounded so he wasn't gonna
want it to come out that way you know
what i mean and so i had to rearrange
him and make it
feel like a record and then uh you know
he gave me his blessing on it but yeah
shout out to doc
yeah it's crazy because you would think
like coming to tde like
i feel like fans expect you to just get
the automatic kendrick record
yeah yeah and i don't feel like that's
happened for a while man like they think
it's like
that's what i'm telling like y'all
thinking it hasn't been like that for a
very long time they think it's like a td
castle you walk in and then you just get
records from everybody i'm like
is crazy though yeah thank you did he
make you play golf with him first
he did not make me play i'm glad he
didn't because i'm horrible in golf but
uh
nah um that was actually one of the ones
that uh my manager came
uh he also managed his q and so he
pitched it to him and uh but
i didn't i wasn't sure if he was gonna
do it you know what i mean but uh he
came through and he killed that [ __ ]
though
i [ __ ] with q man because q will all
like it don't matter
if you're major like if he [ __ ] with
you like he'll do the first
exactly and if he's like in that head
space like i like q because
it's like that one thing if he [ __ ]
with you he'll do the verse and then
also like
if q is working like he's working and
you know
like you'll have like i remember i had i
was listening to like like
burner styles pee album and that fool
was on there and i'm like man that's why
accused the realest because he'll tap in
with whoever
like i know him and freddie got some
[ __ ] on the way that i just heard that's
crazy
i'm already knowing that's probably
crazy super crazy i need to give freddy
or some [ __ ] shout out to freddie
freddie is hard bro we'll make it happen
man
yeah no a thousand percent i definitely
need to do that yeah um
all right so the album comes out well
it's not let's just we're going to drop
this on friday so this would be a nice
so
so the album is out because it albums
out yeah miss out go listen to beginners
right now
can we hey okay so can we can we talk
about the logic
lines yeah yeah let's do it um i've
known logic for a very long time
uh i don't
take him as a culture vulture no
obviously i'm a white man in hip-hop
so you know you could think what you
want about that yeah um
but you know i kind of have known
dude since about 2013 and you know i
know him as like a
hardcore hip-hop fan like that's how me
and him connected was through
conversations about like equipment
you know just just a lot of rap [ __ ]
yeah um
he seems like i mean he's a very
disliked guy the last
five or six years but but what what is
um what what's the issue with logic and
why did he get that those bars well for
me it's funny because that's the
misunderstanding of the line and i
learned a good lesson on that i learned
two lessons timing
uh as far as reading the room and also
like if you're gonna say something
you you need to kind of go in a little
bit more detail when i rap i just kind
of
rap about what i'm feeling at the time
so uh i
too have loved logic since like like
damn near 2010
and um kind of going off what we said
earlier like if i'm a fan of you i hold
you accountable
a lot of fans thought that i was saying
he's a culture vulture of hip-hop
that's not what i was talking about you
know what i'm saying and so
um from a hip-hop standpoint you can't
talk about the last 10 years of hip-hop
without talking about logic like he's
he's in that category you know he's not
as big as kendrick and them but he's in
that category
some respect on his name yeah yeah no a
thousand percent so
what i was speaking about was the fact
that logic is a black man
and uh logic is uh somebody that has
talked about black ply black struggle
that's what he talked about on his come
up and then when he got to a certain
album
um i think it was everybody um and he
touched on a lot of issues that was
going on in america suicide transgenders
gays everybody
and i personally felt like he didn't
touch on black lives matter enough
so when i said the line about the
culture i just meant
black culture is what got you to the
point that you're at so when you're
at the top of your platform where now
you're ready
to explode to the world to have this
huge artist like
talk about us too and that's what i
meant by that
and um that just comes from my passion
for black
culture in general and black lives and
what's going on with black people and
stuff like that i mean
it came from that perspective you know
what i'm saying it had nothing to do
with hip-hop i had nothing to do with
records or rapping and nothing like that
like i'm a logic fan but like i said
earlier like i
i hold people accountable i would never
want somebody i would want somebody to
do the same thing with me if i get to a
certain
platform and now i'm about to have that
album that explodes it's like you still
gotta
remember why you're doing this which is
to you know bring awareness you know
what i mean to people and stuff like
that yeah i think
i actually was not a fan of that album
that's probably uh
and now exactly i think a lot of people
that were hardcore logic fans weren't
yeah yeah honestly like this last album
that just dropped is incredible was the
last album
like the first album i've [ __ ] with
since his second album the
incredible journey or just true story
one yeah no pressure is incredible no
pressure's fire
but yeah i think that like i don't know
man i just think that
you know i think that's a fair criticism
um you know i think that album everybody
was like
i think he was dealing with a lot of the
biracial [ __ ] he's probably meant to be
yeah
i think that he was just probably having
a lot people don't know but logic is
black yeah no
thousands what do you say i think he was
probably having a lot of meetings and
stuff like that you know i mean i don't
want to speculate too much but i think
that
people were telling them like this is
what you have to do to get to the next
to the next level you know what i mean
and that's my my whole thing is you know
i'm just if i'm a fan of you you know
what i mean i'm going to
i'm like i said i'm one of the more
honest artists in this [ __ ] i don't
i don't necessarily i don't have the
goals like everybody else has to be the
the greatest of all time because i don't
believe that exists like in 10 years
there's going to be somebody that's
going to tell you nba young boy is
better than kendrick it's going to
happen like so
listen there is already a generation of
hip-hop fans right now that's a straight
face exactly so for me it's like
i just want to make impact and i want to
i want to broker
honest conversations and try to make an
impact to where people
you know elevate their their honesty
their accountability their
responsibility whatever the case may be
and so but like i said i'm not going to
escape my accountability in it
i didn't read the room you know logic
when i wrote it he wasn't retired he's
retired now he's trying to do his own
thing you know what i mean and so that
is something that
if i could go back i wouldn't i just
wouldn't say the line out there because
it's like
let him do his thing you know what i
mean and so it would be a conversation
that if i ever met him i would have with
him personally still
but um um i wouldn't necessarily put it
out for the record i don't think there's
a chance in hell he doesn't know who you
are like he said oh no he definitely
knows
but i like i like the it's like bro
you're you're a hip-hop stan
and this is top dog entertainment yeah
you know and he's a kendrick stan
exactly exactly yeah but he is shout out
to logic though like his career
musically like
i'd be lucky if i was able to reach that
level
i'm glad you made that clear because
like like you know a lot of people took
it from a hip-hop standpoint which i
can't blame them and it's funny because
when they dropped them like
oh damn it does sound like i'm saying
that like like it does sound like yeah
because i was thinking like you know
like yeah i know logic is like a real
hip-hop head like this guy you know he
works with no ideas
you know you can't you can't and that's
what i'm saying like you can't say logic
isn't
a hip-hop guy and that's not what i was
saying but you know
no no i understand why i understand why
you said that though yeah i think that
what's going on right now man it's very
important like that's why i tell
everybody like
you know if you're let alone just the
normal citizen who has empathy and
and and gives a [ __ ] about your neighbor
or just you know
it's hard to get people to care about
[ __ ] that doesn't directly affect them
but specifically if you
are a part of any sort of
black culture and i mean that as far as
you know
you could be a radio personality you
could be
somebody who does youtube [ __ ] you could
be whatever but if you're benefiting off
the back of black culture
like bro i've literally made my entire
career
off of black music that's my whole life
revolves around
black culture since i was 15 64
really since i was like 12. yeah yeah
even earlier you know but like
you know i had a very interesting
upbringing like i was raised in a house
where my best friend was black and his
grandma lived with me and his sister
lived with me when i was a kid you know
so like
it frustrates me so much to see almost
like you just said with the logic thing
you know logic
obviously african-american men yeah so
you know it's a little different but
it frustrates me to be like yo how are
you
like talking in and out of drake songs
every day on the radio
and like afraid to [ __ ] up your social
media stuff no and it's crazy because
you posted a video on instagram
talking about that and um i i got a lot
of respect for you
when you said that you know man i saw
your instagram post when you said that
you know like you know
every day you're talking in and out of
drake songs and and black culture you're
going to clubs and playing black music
you're
there's black people there these are the
people that are literally affording you
your life
and then when something happens you know
it's like you're you're like
in for when it's convenient it's like
you're tiptoeing in and out of the
[ __ ] co
like but when it when [ __ ] hits the fan
like you gotta like
you gotta scream at the top of your legs
exactly and shout out to jack harlow
because i even hit him up and reach out
to him because
uh he was he was front line when that
[ __ ] was going on he was marching
every single day posting [ __ ] every
single day uh speaking at pep rallies
and stuff like that like
like i feel like i i [ __ ] with that and
like i always say i always
you know play the other side of the
fence and and have accountability
um to the black people because eminem
did this [ __ ] on the bt awards where he
made like a free speech and they [ __ ]
on him and they [ __ ] on him and i i
feel like you know black people have to
stop doing that as well it's like when
when there are white people that want to
join this side you know
and that was before that was yeah two
years ago that was like two or three
years ago and i feel like i thought it
was dope
this is the biggest white artist from a
rap standpoint in the world he's always
been on this side of the fence it's not
like he's doing this for
like he's always been on the side of the
fence and then we kind of [ __ ] it on him
you know i'ma always hold my people
accountable too and say like that's not
cool you know what i mean like eminem is
somebody that has been on our side of
the culture
you know we have to tackle this [ __ ]
together if we're gonna be able to make
leeway you know
yeah i think too like someone like him
you know like he's got fans
a hundred percent that are racist yeah
and he put that on the line like if you
are racist
don't like don't support me don't [ __ ]
with me there's something cause like i'm
real close
with uh a rapper named ritz who's a
white dude okay um
that's actually hilarious by the way
yeah he's fired
yes okay guys i gotta check and and like
you know
you know i got a boy named jelly roll
and like a lot of time
even like tech9 like is my boy and like
i've done a lot of stuff with strange
music in that just that world
yeah and that world is mostly white fans
yeah
yeah and a lot of them are racist bro
that's crazy there's a lot of tech nine
fans that are racist as [ __ ] that's the
same bro
like straight up and like and and tech
will tell you that too
you know what i'm saying i'm sure um now
he you know he's got an incredible
following
but there's like a real faction of
hip-hop fans that just
that are real like mega ass
[ __ ] bro yeah it's like
it's it's very disappointing but like
you said about the eminem thing like
he might piss off a huge part of his fan
base by saying something
but what he might also do is even if
it's
a thousand people who hear that
freestyle yeah and it teaches them
something and then they go
google it and then they're like like
they they
become more educated about the situation
where they change their stance on [ __ ]
like
eminem influences people they might be
people who drink mount monster energy
and have you know fox racing cargo
shorts but
but i'm saying like he can reach people
like he and there's going to be
there's going to be parts of the of his
fan base and just anyone anyone in the
country that just aren't
that they're just this is where they are
they're not going to budge yeah i think
it's about 30 and 30. i think it's 30
over here 30 over there but that lasts
you know 40 percent that's in the middle
you know you fight for those you know
what i'm saying and and even more
importantly
there might be other white celebrities
that wanted to say something
and were about to say something and then
saw eminem get killed
and step back and so that's another
reason why i feel like you know we can't
do that is because
you know that's those could it could
have been other
artists or celebrities or whatever that
wanted to say something to stand with us
and it's like we take a step back by
killing them because they might be with
[ __ ] like emergency jumped out the
window and they went crazy i'm just
going i'm just going to chill back you
know what i mean and not say nothing
and it's like we need every single voice
that we can get you know what i mean and
trying to change it you know what i mean
so yeah that's how i feel what do you
think um
if someone's watching this and they're
like
kind of just unsure of the things that
they could probably do to
you know for me like i was one of those
guys who was like you know
and i've been you know any time there's
i mean you know i grew up
like i said my best friend rams is best
man at my wedding like we would we would
be
riding around in this neon when i was
like 14.
he was older than me and we get pulled
over and this food yanked out the car
put on the curb and then they would be
interrogating me like why are we hanging
out
why why are you hanging out with this
like older black kid
you know and so it's always been
something close to my heart but like
for me it's like okay like
i want to put my money where my mouth is
but i didn't know where to where to
donate because you know you never know
like with
so many of these that's real it's like
it's so agenda
like yeah so i just call killer mike any
time i got any sort of questions about
that that's a good
person to call call killer mike i say
hey man i really want to post i want to
donate some money and i want to
shed a light on some charities like just
tell me what you
tell me what to do yeah he's a good
leader in this [ __ ] yeah and he's like
yo there's
you know this this this cool you know
what i'm saying and then obviously you
know protesting and
i think i might have caught i might have
caught the ronin when i was out
protesting
i might have that might have been where
i got it but um but i do think that
there's like
like is i know that a lot of people get
[ __ ] for
being social media you know like
quote unquote like oh you're doing this
for the gram or whatever and there's a
lot of that
yeah but i do think either way it's you
know it's better than nothing
i think the black square [ __ ] was kind
of corny to be honest yeah yeah i feel
like um
it's like everything yeah looking back
on it i was like uh you know that didn't
really help
um but i think it's a growing process
and uh like i have
because i worked at a um i worked at a
corporate company
um before i got signed that's what i was
working at so i had a lot of white
co-workers and friends still
and some of them even reached out to me
was like you know what do we do and for
me i just think that the biggest thing
that you can do in the day-to-day life
is to just
try to understand what's going on and
and do your research and empathize with
it
and you know hold other people
accountable like i think that that's the
bare minimum that you can do
because people that are of that world
that are naive quote unquote you're not
naive you grew up in this black culture
but there's other people that are naive
because they didn't grow up here
but they do they are humans and they
feel for us now because they're aware
so i tell them like all the people that
are in your circle you just have to hold
them accountable when y'all are having
these conversations and stuff like that
like
you can't be afraid to speak up to them
because that's your quote-unquote
friend or whatever i like to call
there's like these white people
conversations that happen
where there's no other races around
exactly and then that's when you really
find out like that's a fact whether it's
people you work with or you might be at
a [ __ ]
liquor store or something not as well
somebody in line might say some slick
[ __ ] to you because you're another white
guy
and they think that like oh it's all
cool like you know what i mean yeah like
bro like what
bro what and those are the conversations
that i feel like everybody that asked me
to be like that's not enough that's not
cool like you know what i mean and those
are the conversations that you gotta
hold people accountable you know at the
bare bare minimum
um and then you know if you want to go
that extra mile you know you do do your
research i i advise that you go off of
facebook too please
that place is the [ __ ] cesspool of
the internet it's the worst it's up
there with twitter twitter i think it's
like
the twitter facebook is where like
the memes and like the fake news story
bro when i
my mom has hit me with so much crazy
[ __ ] like is this true
and i'm like mom did you see that on
facebook
yeah like well listen then no yeah then
no it's
yo what's up man boulette kev here
shouting out to the homies at odd socks
for sponsoring the bootleg cab podcast
and showing us love man
and let me tell you something we don't
take everyone's money
that's not true we'll take everyone's
money but donald trump's but with that
being said we [ __ ] with odd socks all
right
um i've been rocking odd socks for like
eight years now
and um man christmas time coming up make
sure you get you some odd socks
first of all let's talk about these
basics right here
these joints are the most comfortable
socks i've ever put on my feet all right
no design no license but just crazy so
make sure you get some of those
all right then they got the nickelodeon
they got the uh
scarface they got tapatio they got wwe
how about chef from southpark you know
what i'm saying whatever you need
shout out stone cold steve austin by the
way these are the socks that i wear when
i uh
drink pbr and yell at my wife uh
anyway um shout out to old dirty bastard
too
go to oddssoxofficial.com right now
all right right now go to
oddssocksofficial.com use the keyword
bootleg kev
and you will receive 20 off at checkout
go do that
there by the way shout out to kendrick
uh i i gotta address the whole
the rumor of him leaving tde he put that
to bed today yeah how about i say you
see the video the blue is closed
yeah stuffed animal it was hilarious bro
yeah no i thought it was really really
funny and i think that like
you know i hope he's putting out some
music soon
um yeah but is it is it kind of like
the gift and the curse of the tde thing
because any sort of like like kendrick
is like
you know i i put him top five ever yeah
yeah
i always tell people because there's
like og hip-hop fans that tell me i'm
crazy but i'm like yo
you're gonna put biggie in the top five
which is fair off of two albums yeah
exactly
but kendrick got yeah three classics
that's a fact that's a fact and we're
not talking about section 80 yeah
yeah or the the kendrick lamari exactly
or
or you know even untitled you know but
like we're just talking about his three
official
good kid the butterfly and uh dab yeah
section ladies up there with that with
those wrestlers you know what i'm saying
but but um yeah i just feel like
everywhere you're gonna go
yeah you're gonna get kendra questions
exactly 1000 um
it's funny because i was just talking uh
to punch about this the other day
um i don't think that there's been an
artist that's been in my position
as far as like the amount of pressure
and what i mean by that is that
you know i'm the first artist that has
to be broken without dave free being
around
he hasn't been involved in any part of
my career and that's not a shot at him
he just left
when i was coming in so this timing um
there hasn't been an artist
a new artist to drop when the thirst
level of the bigger artist has been
this high you know what i mean it's been
three years it's been three years and
it's been
four for zay and it's been like three
for sizza it's been like two for
for rock uh two and a half q last year
earlier that was cute
early last year yeah like like a year
and a half ago you get them saying so
for all the bigger artists
uh there's never been a younger artist
to drop when there's been that thirst
level that high you know what i mean so
it's like
i'm in a position where i have to make
people care i have to do the creative
direction without dave
and everybody just wants a dot album you
know what i mean so
i'm definitely under like the most
pressure that um any td
artist has been under but at the same
time um i always try to look at pros and
cons in every situation instead of
saying what was me
and the pro is that like all eyes are on
me you know what i mean and i know that
there's going to be a lot of fans that's
just like
you know oh reason dropping cool he's
out the way uh you know like where's the
next album or whatever but
there are going to be those handful of
fans that still go listen because
you know it's still td and i think that
this project is strong to where they're
gonna know
you know what i mean that like oh this
dude is not just like another dude
that's just
dropping like this is a very very strong
project so that's what i'm looking
forward to
what's your uh you know i know you got
isaiah on the album and uh
i've been waiting for like you said man
yeah i think he's one of the greats
i think he's somebody who don't get
enough uh i mean also he hasn't put an
out mountain
yeah exactly it's like like to the other
side of it yeah but what's your
relationship like with him
um you know i think like i said there
was
there was just there's just been so many
rumors about his career and like you
know i know he's still on the label i
think for a while there there was like
some speculation that he might have
not been on the label but like what
what's y'all's relationship and dynamic
uh we have a great relationship and uh
shout out to za um
me and za around the same age and and i
appreciate zay because
he's been through a lot of [ __ ] that i'm
still going through
right and um he holds me accountable um
without going into detail he called me
and helped me accountable about the
logic [ __ ] just about like
bro read the room you know what i mean
like not necessarily um
getting on me about what i said but just
like why you know what i mean and so
you know there were things that he said
that i agree with there was things he
said i didn't agree with but at the end
of the day i love anybody that will call
me
that cares about me and hold you
accountable because that is a tough
conversation to have with anybody
that you love you know what i mean so
what's the kind of people you want
around you those kind of people you want
around you 100
and so you know i [ __ ] with that we have
a great relationship i tell people all
the time zayn is a lunatic
and that's part of the re you know part
of the delays in his music as well is
that he's [ __ ] crazy like zay
he's he's very very detailed about his
music he cares about it a lot
he cares about his music a lot a lot
he's very connected to it and so
you know until it's where he wants it to
be and the records that he wants
and him and top get on the same page
about that
uh because it has to be records that he
loves and is connected to and it also
has to be records at top
you know believes can elevate his you
know his status
so you know that that that takes a
minute sometimes and it's definitely a
push and pull thing because
top is probably the hardest critic of
music that i've ever met
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy like yeah i've
heard it
so but shout out to zeto i don't think
that people have to wait much longer
though
um where will there be a continuation
of the storyline of lambo truck
like you and kaz like might do a part
two or something like uh there's
we we've talked about it because we're
working on a project and um so there's
gonna be
you and kaz are working on a joint
project there will be yeah we're working
on it we're actually almost done um
it's not going to be like the kendrick
cole album no it's not going to be like
that yeah and i told
him me and kyle's talked about that i
said bro we're going to do this like
i don't want it like i said i came in
this [ __ ] as a fan i never want to do
to fans what other artists have done
that's frustrating because i've been a
fan you know what i'm saying so i told
kyle's like if we're gonna put this [ __ ]
out there
and talk about it on the internet like
it's gotta come out it's gonna come out
and i was like and even if the labels
don't agree then we gotta just like leak
it and
we just gotta both take it on the
channel from like sound cloud i don't
know how it goes i don't know how i got
out
i'm saying like it is what it is but it
has to come out you know what i mean
like
and so that's that's how i feel about it
but uh nah um
it would have been done by now but i was
really just tying up this project it was
really like um
i forgot how long it and how many hours
it takes to send videos and i mean to do
videos and
get content together and all of that
[ __ ] and so i had to kind of back out we
were having sessions and i had to kind
of back out of those sessions for a
minute
to get my [ __ ] tied up uh but shout out
to him how many records in
you guys we probably got like eight
right now we're trying to make sure the
project is only like seven records but
we want to make like 15 and then pick
the string
yeah so i actually just had a phone call
with him last night because i sent him
two joints that i did
and um i was like you know like i'm back
working again right right yeah i'm back
working again so like let's get cooking
and he was like
thank god because like i just been
missing as far as like the process of it
so uh
yeah we'll we'll probably wrap that up
like within the next month month and a
half what is uh
do you remember what top's reaction was
to that song originally when you heard
kaz's portion top called me and said he
said
snicker top is crazy he said yeah i
heard you was robin cole
tell kaz remember it's just a song
[Laughter]
he said just tell them make sure your
members is just a song bro don't don't
don't come over it's not where you want
to come over here with that
i do think it's dope though that you
guys are going to do a project together
because i do feel like uh no matter what
dreamville and tde are going to always
be
they're they're the integrity yeah in
hip-hop when it comes to creatively
like the artists that y'all like that
everyone signs like i feel like that
there's two constants
when it comes to integrity like you know
you're going to get a certain level of
music or quality when
you know when it comes to those two
camps yeah yeah and just calling
kendrick
kind of having a simultaneous come up
yeah yeah
it's been like right there you know what
i mean yeah like cole was on the
freshman cover year after kendrick was
on the right exactly
and then it's like you know uh i think
dot drop or uh code dropped
sideline story and then dot drop good
kid mass city and then you know
um uh what was the record on section 80
that j cole produced the big one
oh yeah uh [ __ ]
yo yo you should get some cold beats
reason bro i'll hit him up for some like
i'm like duh like what are you but
he's working on his album but i'm like
my [ __ ] i know there's records that
you're not going to beat
i'm like i know if there's records that
you're not using bro he's actually a
super super fire
producer he's well you know what i mean
like nah cole is a dope human people be
forgetting that [ __ ] when cold first
came out like he was low-key like
producing for other artists a little bit
a thousand percent
thousand percent you know and birthing
ideas you know what i mean as far as
like from a writing perspective not
necessarily writing but just birthing
ideas you know i tell people
those are the best producers to me are
the ones shout out kyle banks he does
this
that's why i love working with him but
like as an artist it's hard to keep
coming up with new ideas but the
producers that make beats and then
kind of give you ideas of cadences and
melodies and stuff like that like those
are the things
well that's produced that is producing
this [ __ ] is beat man it's just beat
making you what i'm saying like which is
no offense to that if you were a beat
maker shout out to you
but it's like there's a difference
between a producer and a beat maker and
i tell people that too it's like
you know there's there's some producers
that don't make beats but they produce
like shout out to diddy like he was one
of those people he didn't make beats
but he'd be in the room in the room like
yeah like you know what i mean like
let's do this let's do that and that's
an important thing as well you get what
i'm saying so
so yeah yeah um i i i was a
not was i am a fan and i i always wanted
that project though
and you know i just wish that like the
world would have got it you know what i
mean and so
yeah and that's another thing that i'm
i'm pushing to was like this
relationship with
dre bill and tde to just come a little
closer um i was the only artist that was
on the revenge album you know what i
mean and i was proud of that me and
j.i.d i took a pay cut to go on that
tour because i felt like it was
important for the culture not for
you you know i mean like top still
didn't you know what i mean feel because
he's a businessman like that don't make
sense but
i took a pay cut because i feel like it
was important and me and coz making this
project to me is important and i just
feel like it's important for our two
labels
to grow a relationship and you know
we're always going to have friendly
competition
but at the same time we do need to grow
a little bit closer of a relationship no
i think it's dope like i remember as a
kid
the rough riders in cash money going on
tour together yeah yeah there was [ __ ]
like that going on that like that [ __ ]
is iconic
and i feel like that [ __ ] is kind of
missing like you said like the fact you
went on tour with with jid
the super fire i just feel like that
that kind of like
you know like a scissor [ __ ] ari
linux bro would be so crazy
would be so crazy bro even like how they
do dreamville fest i'm like if
and we did the championship tour i'm
like if td and dreamville did a tour bro
it would be literally insane bro like it
was like
and on from a business perspective
there's so much money that can be made
what show me that was uh days in vegas
did you go to days of view of course
yeah like bro that [ __ ] was the most lit
festival i've ever performed at because
you had hip-hop fans at a festival going
crazy and they don't get the opportunity
to go to festivals and see their
favorite artists i thought that the
lineup was epic i def
the execution of the festival yeah the
executioner festival was like a little a
little shaky i also was
[ __ ] blown out of my mind for like
three days straight at that tour
like yeah high as [ __ ] and yeah i was on
mushrooms and [ __ ] and
it was a great it was a great i enjoyed
like you said like
the music on friday and sunday the
friday was drained
sunday was tde the fact each camp had
their own day that [ __ ] was so hard bro
then kendra came out in a cowboy hat i
didn't know what the heck was going on
and people didn't think it was you look
like the [ __ ] the the monster and
jeepers creepers like yeah like i was
like what the [ __ ] is that
but like imagine if like we had more
songs together and if on both days you
were getting like
what i'm saying like because the lambo
truck there it went
crazy crazy it went crazy and i'm like
bro if everybody on the labels had
different records with each other like
and we were like doing [ __ ] on you guys
should do like would have been stupid
five dates i agree yeah just like pick
the biggest
cities you know what it is where it
becomes tough
is and and you know i think the only
reason something like that won't happen
or why
it might not happen is deciding who goes
last
yeah and that's and that's to me that's
what kills so many moments
in hip-hop is the that part of it
is like who goes last who what what
label is the best kind of almost like
kendrick and cole would almost
like when i saw the drake and little
wayne tour when they were going back and
forth
the [ __ ] was kind of fly yeah i mean
obviously drake's going to go last if
anyone's going to disaster but
with with cole and kendrick is is
there's really no
definitive way to pick that exactly what
i think they should hey yo we're in la
yeah kendrick's going to go last we're
going to do
atlanta i don't know maybe you do that's
what i was gonna say like cause i've had
conversations with my homies about this
just spitballing and talking [ __ ]
i feel like they should just divide the
country in half and
like you know what i'm gonna take those
i'm gonna take the east coast you take
the west coast you're gonna say when we
on the west you go last week on the east
i go
like l.a san francisco charlotte
atlanta new york yep exactly and call it
a day you get them saying like and i
feel like if they did that
and maybe texas or something yeah yeah
yeah and three and three
three and three and just you know dot
gold last over here kogo laughs over
there that's what eminem and jay-z did
they didn't even know they did that they
did they did two shows they did detroit
yeah in new york and they did new york
and detroit they did the
baseball stadium or whatever the big
stadium is and then in new york they did
yankee stadium that's fine i had no idea
that that happened yeah they only did
two shows it was called the home to home
tour so it was like each artist did
and in detroit jay open for m that's how
that's hard that's all right i [ __ ] with
that
yeah like yeah that [ __ ] would be crazy
that's tight though like that's what i'm
saying like in
in if they did a show like that where
they went back and forth bro like
like those are moments that like it
doesn't matter what the ticket costs
like
because it's priceless fans yeah like
like it's just take off take my money
yeah take all my money
that's how i felt about that day in
vegas tour i didn't have to pay for my
tickets
how much do you need when people saw the
lineup kendrick
i had homies hitting me up like before i
buy my ticket is this fake like like
have you
gotten paid for this [ __ ] like that was
the craziest lineup ever assembled
it was insane because we did our real
street fest in uh
august yep yep and they announced that
[ __ ]
and i was like oh my god
[Laughter]
how much money did they spend on the
lineup like how did how is this even
possible like
who's funding this jesus christ they had
like
five major headliners there like people
this is the person you picked to close
the enti and they had like five of them
insane
it was crazy bro i don't even think
tyler closed out the day he was on
who he did travis closed out that day
travis closed out that's what i'm saying
like it was
insane bro that travis was there i want
to say cardi was there i'm not 100 sure
she was supposed to be there okay that's
what it was she was supposed to be there
okay uh uzi was there like code
dot um uh tyler like that's what i'm
saying like they that that's fine
100 it was crazy bro it was super super
crazy so
yeah i just want like us to create more
moments like that you get them saying
yeah i think that's true man i think
that a lot of ego i'm not saying that
that's the case here but i just think in
general like in hip-hop there's a lot of
[ __ ] that like
i think i call it business ego which is
not like the people it's more about like
the business like of the the two sides
like it doesn't make sense for our side
well it doesn't make sense for ourselves
you know what i'm saying like so i don't
think it's necessarily artistic
what if we just did something for the
fans wouldn't that be crazy like
nah that'd be super crazy look man um
the album officially out
or project or mixtape or whatever we're
calling it whatever we want to call it
um does this mean we're gonna have to
wait four years for your next project
it does not and that's one thing i've
taken pride in with the labels that i do
feel like i've changed
uh the mode of how things work a little
bit uh even to the fact like
fans are giving me a lot of slack like
man we've had eight singles like we
heard the whole
album i'm like well no only three of
them are on the project like
because tde artists don't just drop
singles that's not a thing you know what
i mean and i was the first one that just
was just putting [ __ ] out like i just
get on top's nerves and tell you but let
me shut reason up and put something out
yeah um but i said it to say no like i'm
almost done with my debut album
um i'm hoping to drop uh like second
quarter so that's what i'm aiming for
that's what my managers and
all of us are talking about uh so that's
what we push them for
maybe a little cause uh trying to get
that out before my debut so i'm trying
to get the cause and reason [ __ ] out
january february i am that's what i'm
aiming for that's what i'm aiming for i
gotta i gotta double check with kyle's
schedule because i know that he's
wrapping up his album
um but we've already been in the grants
that like we're just gonna put that out
we don't gotta do nothing crazy behind
it yeah just throw it out it's just for
the fans it's just for the fans like we
just put it out maybe shoot a video or
two yeah
a couple videos let it do what it's
going to do you get what i'm saying
and hopefully get some features from
both sides and that'll be the closest
thing that people what we're trying to
do is make it the closest thing that
people can get to a td dream bill tape
so we're trying to
get features from both sides that'll be
hard like heavily featured
exactly heavily featured you know what i
mean and get some [ __ ] from our side get
some [ __ ] from their side
put it out for the fans we don't got to
do nothing crazy absol and j.i.d ever
been on a record together
not from my understanding but i feel
like that would be crazy though i think
that would be crazy
i'm gonna put my vote out there and
j.i.d you're my guy but
ab will get him i think we'll get him by
the way um i know that uh
dj had had this big thing that you got
you got you gotta ate up by absolutely
yes
i didn't think it was that close you you
didn't think it was that close i think
head was full of [ __ ] oh okay thank you
i better say okay yeah i just think head
likes to poke at you because you're for
sure but
yeah and he's like into a high standard
and he knows that he can get a reaction
so you know he knows i'm so competitive
he can get a reaction but uh
but not like like so did go crazy but
like i tell people all the time like i
always
i always make sure that like my verse is
there before i
send it off and i like honestly i like
when artists hear my verse and try to
like go crazy i'll do it because it
makes the song better you know what i
mean like
i don't want you to send a [ __ ]
because then i'm not gonna put the song
out you know what i mean and so
but i will say shout outs two artists
shout out boogie and rap city i probably
won't be sending them any more verses
first
uh because boogie on trapton yeah crazy
bro boogie went crazy on trap 10 and
then rhapsody i can make it went so
so crazy so i'm like y'all two i gotta
get in the studio we gotta wrap we gotta
write this
we gotta do it together we gotta do this
together y'all can't just keep on like
having my
my [ __ ] and like yeah yeah you take two
months to write a verse and send me back
a [ __ ]
ether nas verse like nah we're not doing
that no more boom well look uh go get
the album
reason uh the merge is out is the merch
drop yeah
uh march yeah it would it would have
dropped by yes okay so the merch will be
out on friday which is it's
past friday no it's friday now we're
dropping this on friday we're dropping
this yeah so the merch is out now
yeah 100 boom reasons let's go perfect
man
that's dope